follow your passion the number one most
important rule hands down is that you
follow your passion if you're trying to
start a business if you are not super
excited about your company if you're not
trying to change the world in a positive
way somehow through your your business
you're not going to have success and if
you look at every entrepreneur who's
made it they kept going through all the
hard times because they just absolutely
loved what they were doing where most
people the same the logical people would
quit would move on with something else
because it didn't make sense to keep
going the only reason to keep going was
because they love what they were doing
and you have to love your business so
much that you would take on part-time
jobs doing something totally different
just to support your cause because you
love it so much would you do that for
your company are you that guy or girl
because if it's not if you do not love
your business that much that you would
do it regardless of getting paid then
you're in the wrong business and you
need to move on to something else maybe
you're not an entrepreneur I got a
question from a reader Jason we're a
long email basically he's a part-time
freelance film producer he loves making
movies that's his passion and he's been
working at a direct marketing company
i'm assuming just to pay the bills and
the more time he spends their the more
he misses his film business and wishes
he could be doing that instead of direct
marketing you wanted my advice on what
to do he feels like he's living a life
of regret now and is not not a happy
person to me the answer is obvious
you've got to follow your passion how
long you willing to sit in this direct
marketing business wasting away not
following your dreams are you going to
be happy being 50 years old still being
in direct marketing having a you know a
family and being stuck in this job that
you hate going to every day always
regretting that you never went and
actually followed what you're excited
about I understand that you got to make
money right that's it's part of life
right you have and make money but if
you're going to take a job get a job in
something that you're going to learn
from so the only reason I would stay in
direct marketing at this company as if I
felt like
that experience was going to teach me
how to maybe sell my films how to
distribute my films the great thing here
Jason is that you have discussed and
developed what your passion is you've
understood what your passion is and this
is great it's a huge step because a lot
of entrepreneurs don't start a business
around their passion their sort of
business just trying to make money and
it never works out so the fact that you
have identified your passion puts you
ahead of a lot of other people but now
you got to act on it you got to do
something about it and it's great that
you have a job when you're starting part
time I'm all for that it's a great way
to start a business but you going to do
two things okay first you got to make
sure you're doing something every day at
least every week to grow your business
you have to do something regularly to
grow your business it can't just all be
about your job you have to do something
in your own company to get momentum
because a lot of these things take time
but if you do steps every day something
small everyday an email a proposal
you're filming something something every
day over time those small steps will add
up to something big something that you
can be proud of something that you can
hang your hat on and say I made that and
progress starts to happen and results
start to happen even if they're slow you
have to make sure that momentum is
building and not let things just die
with your company okay so small step
every day a tiny small step every day
for your business the second thing is go
get a job where you're going to learn
something okay if you're tired of direct
marketing you've learned everything you
can learn from it leave that job and go
work for a different business where you
can learn a skill set the ideal thing is
to go work for another film company work
for a company that maybe has 10
employees join them help out as much as
you can do what you're hired to do but
then also try to try to get involved in
the business in as much detail as you
can every entrepreneur they have tons of
work okay they may not be able to afford
to pay you huge rates but there's no
entrepreneur that says oh yeah
everything's covered i'm just chillin
you know I don't have any extra work
entrees are struggling and they're
they're working crazy hours if you go to
accompany a small company offer to work
for the entrepreneur and start taking on
projects that are outside what they
directly hired you for they're going to
give it to you
and what it's going to do is teach you
about the film business and how to make
movies how to distribute movies how to
hire the right people how to market
yourself all the things that you're
going to have to learn probably the hard
way if you do it yourself so they're
paying you to learn about the film
business they're paying you to make
mistakes in the film industry so that
when you're ready to go out and do your
own thing on the full time basis you
have contacts you have experience you
know what you're doing and you
dramatically increase the chances of you
being successful so you're already on
the right path and you develop your
passion you know what it is and that's
great but the next step is you got to
get experience in your field get a job
where you're learning something and make
sure that you're taking action every day
doing something for your own business to
start building up momentum to eventually
get you to the point where you can
follow your passion full-time have your
own great business have a real impact on
the world and make you so much happier
then you're going to be in this direct
marketing business when you're 50 years
old looking back and living your life
full of regrets okay I don't want that
for you I don't want that for anybody
who's watching the video if you have a
passion you go and you chase it you have
a dream you got to hunt that thing down
until you either accomplish it or it's
not your dream anymore you owe it to
yourself your family your community that
people around you your customers
everybody you owe it to yourself to be
the best entrepreneur best person you
can be and chase down your dreams don't
let anything hold you back including the
story that you're telling yourself
believe for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it always makes me want to do more
and I'd love to hear what you have to
think leave a comment underneath you
have a question you're struggling with
something with your business leave it
below make a video response for you I
love seeing the comments come in they
keep me motivated and make me want to do
more so thank you so much and I'll see
you soon
you